good evening ladies ladies and gentlemen
it's a delight to be here at the uh next
big
question uh thank you for joining us I
think you're in for a very
thought-provoking and fascinating
uh evening my name is Frank OD day I'm a
very recent board member to uh this
organization C4 the Canadian Institute
for advanced
research I became involved with the
organization in just such an event the
next big question the last event was
being held in Ottawa about a year ago uh
I went and I became engaged with the
research the minds and then after
meeting with some of the management in
board fascinated with the organization
it is doing great work and I trust
you'll find the same at the end of this
evening in a few minutes we're going to
hear from three researchers all
addressing and answering the same
question who are you each with a
different answer each based on their own
research and collaboration with other
sear
colleagues please engage with them at
the end of the uh at the end of the
evening when our CEO and president Aviva
hoek will join us here on the stage and
lead a discussion with the three
researchers and then take a few
questions from the audience I hope you
find it as fascinating and as
interesting as the one I saw in
Ottawa before we get going let me tell
you a little about
sear in my own words sear tries to bring
together the finest Minds in the world
to address topics that will change
change the way we live work and play in
this world big questions and we bring
together the finest Minds in the world
really remarkable
organization started in 1982 with three
clear goals one to focus on Advanced
research that creates breakthrough
knowledge two advances Canadians
research Community Canada's research
community and three fuels
innovation today we mobilize 385
researchers 107 institutions 16
countries our Scholars represent 50
different fields of
research and 40% are in the top 1% of
their fields today there's no University
anywhere in the world that has this
concentration of brain power we're very
proud that these researchers agreed to
join us in pursuing the next big
question
none of this would happen without the
support support of
individuals foundations and
corporations we also have received
funding from the government of Canada
the provincial governments of Ontario
Alberta and British
Columbia if you're not already a
supporter I respectfully submit that
perhaps you think about doing so a
donation to sear is truly an investment
in the
future
one of the particular benefits that I
enjoy so much working at sear is working
with our president and CEO Aviva
hoek I'd like to invite her to the p uh
Podium now to get the evening underway
thank you all once again for joining us
and please join me in welcoming haviv
hoai good evening ladies and gentlemen
before I introduce our speakers I want
to thank Frank for being our Host this
evening Frank joined our board this
winter and immediately became one of our
most active directors thank you for the
entrepreneurial energy and passion that
you bring to our Advanced research work
in Canada we're really happy to have you
on the team now tonight we're really
fortunate to have with us three sefar
researchers who not only are at the
Forefront of their respective Fields but
are also very talented explainers and
story ret tellers our first speaker is
Irene bloomr Irene is a Canadian who now
resides in California where she's an
associate professor of Sociology at the
University of California she studies the
Nexus of immigration politics and
National identities please welcome Irene
bloomr who will answer the question who
are you by making the case that you are
your citizenship an interesting thing on
a day like today isn't
that
well I'd like to thank you all uh for
coming out especially on an election day
when you might be wanting to find out
what's happening in Atlantic Canada
through tweets um or maybe not right um
it's also a particular pleasure to be
here in Toronto because one thing that
haviva did not mention is that my family
immigrated to Canada in the 1970s and
like so many other immigrants we first
landed in Toronto and so I learned
English in Toronto and spent some years
in the school system um here so it's
really a pleasure to be here uh this
event was planned before uh the election
was called but once I realized that this
event and the election was on the same
day um I did not think it was just
coincidence I actually think it's a
Divine sign that I am right and that you
are your
citizenship so now let me give you some
additional evidence for that
um if you look at a host of different
surveys different opinion polls done by
government done by uh media uh done by
groups such as the association of
Canadian studies you find that roughly
nine out of 10 people living in Canada
say that they feel a sense of belonging
to Canada and that they feel pride in
their identity as Canadians or being in
Canada uh sometimes those percentages
are around 85% 84% sometimes they go up
to 92% but it's a really incredible
number when you think about it imagine
what would happen if nine out of 10
residents of Canada all agreed on tax
policy right or imagine if nine out of
10 you know people in Canada agreed on
the environment and what we should do
about the environment so this really I
think speaks to the notion that
citizenship and feelings of belonging to
a nation or to a country really do
matter to people in a fundamental way
now in the Canadian context we can go a
step further and say well what exactly
is that identity what what does being
Canadian really mean anyways right and
we have some opinion poll survey data on
that and you might want to think before
I go to the next slide you know what
would you think other people in Canada
would say to that question in terms of
your identity um as someone who later
from Toronto moved to Saskatoon uh you
know hockey might be up there um
surprisingly it's not as popular as a
sign of Canadian identity than you might
think um so if you look at what
constitutes Canadian identity this is
based on a poll that the environics
Institute did in
2010 you find that Health Care is really
prominent that over 80% of people
answering this survey said that healthc
care is strongly associated with an
identity as Canadian the Charter of
Rights and Freedoms is a significant uh
source of identity or something that
reflects Canadian identity the flag and
the national parks um and the
interesting thing about these four items
that are sort of topping the list I
think is if you cast your mind back 50
years ago and you imagine what people
might have answered to the question of
Canadian identity 50 years ago at least
three of these four wouldn't have been
there because they didn't
exist um and that ra raises a really
interesting question about the nature of
identities and the nature of identity
change you can see going down the list
um we have you know fewer people who say
the r CMP and multiculturalism still
over a majority of people answering this
poll at least thought that was a
significant a strong part of Canadian
identity the queen when she when this
was pulled was not part of that you know
maybe on Friday there would have been a
little bit more um but you know this is
again a very significant change from 50
years ago now why is this important this
is important because when I said that
these people who are pulled in these
opinion polls responded these ways these
are all residents of Canada which as
many of you probably know includes about
20% of the population of Canada that was
not born in this country so you have a
very significant foreign born population
that was born somewhere else maybe spent
some years growing up there come to
Canada and then they respond in ways
that are very similar to these responses
of all other Canadians who are maybe
born in this country and this really
represents I think an important issue
when we think about identity is this uh
challenge I think about constructing
identities and especially things such as
National identities and Notions of
citizenship in the context of diversity
and this is clearly not just a Canadian
issue this is something that touches
many many countries in the world most of
my research focuses on North America
Canada and the United States and Western
Europe but we can go beyond that as well
now if you look at some of the countries
of Western Europe and North America and
we look at What proportion of the
population is foreign born Bor which
I'll do right now um you'll find perhaps
surprising for some people in this room
that the US is actually not as immigrant
as we might imagine right Canada and
Australia are much more immigrant
countries than the United States is but
the other striking thing I think for
many people is how significantly
immigrant many European countries that
we might not at least in North America
associated with immigration are really
countries of immigration as well so you
know I would draw your attention for
example to the fact that um Switzerland
has many more foreign born people in its
population than the United States and
actually more than Canada and Australia
even um or it's about the same as
Australia um and then countries such as
Sweden and even Spain now which has gone
through massive transformations in the
last two decades are also at a you know
reasonably high level of
immigration why does this matter in the
context of identity over the last year
especially we've been having lots of
debates around multiculturalism and
pluralism
and many of you might remember back in
October uh the chancellor of Germany
Angela Merkel she made headlines when um
she pronounced that
multiculturalism had utterly failed in
Germany and so this cartoon you know
shows Angela Merkel at the grave of
Multicultural Germany which is now
resting in peace she was not the only
one Nicholas sarosi the president of
France made similar statements and just
a few months ago uh David Cameron the
Prime Minister of Great Britain
announced or he he stated that state
multiculturalism was a problem that even
if Britain you know respected diversity
and thought it was a good thing the
government should not be involved and
instead should embrace a muscular
liberalism in its place and Canada has
not been immune to this um back in
October um I was actually at a series of
seafar meetings then and was reading the
globe in mail and uh the glob in mail
came out with a editorial that followed
up on a series that had been doing and
as you can see here the globe's
editorial said multiculturalism should
be struck from the national vocabulary
Canada needs to have the courage to
build a successful society around the
concept of citizenship now what this
suggests is that there is a
contradiction if not an outright
conflict between diversity
multiculturalism politics of pluralism
on the one hand and common citizenship
national identity like I suggested in
those first slides on the other hand and
one of the things that my research is
pointing to is that that is a completely
false dichotomy and in fact that our
public policies can help constitute our
national identities and this notion that
nine out of 10 people in Canada say yeah
you know I belong to this country
citizenship is part of my
identity so I want to not just pose the
question of who am I I'm a citizen
because I'm sure if you know tomorrow
and a week from now you're sitting in
the TTC and someone goes up to you say
says who are you you're not going to
immediately say oh I'm a Canadian
citizen you know that's that's my
primary identity um it might be true if
you go traveling and someone asks who
are you you might say Canadian as a
first answer to that question um but we
all know that our identities are
multiple depending on the context
depending on what you're doing depending
on who's asking the question you might
answer that question differently what my
research on identity and citizenship
shows however is that that constitution
of who I am that answer to that question
is fundamentally influenced by things
such as public policy and so I think all
three of us tonight are going to give
you different stories based on our
research on how identity is constructed
what are the means by which we get this
sense of who we are in relation to
others and my contribution to this
discussion would be that when you're
voting and the government who's going to
follow up from that vote makes decisions
on healthare makes decisions on the
environment on Military engagement that
actually might have an effect on your
own identity and future Generations
identity as whether they belong or not
and how they feel about things such as
citizenship now what I want to do is I
want to give you a little bit of
evidence from some research I did based
on a Canada US comparison and so if you
look with using sensus data comparing
the proportion of immigrants foreign
born individuals who take up either
Canadian or American citizenship across
the 20th century so across the sweep of
that Century this is what you'll see
the blue bars are the United States the
red bars are Canada um and if you look
carefully across this uh table you'll
see that from about 1900 up to
1970 they're pretty similar you know
sometimes Canada's a little bit higher
sometimes the proportion of naturalized
citizens in the United States are a
little bit higher but following 19771
something remarkable starts happening
the Canadian numbers keep inching up
more and more immigrants take out
citizenship and the US numbers
drop now many of you can probably start
thinking immediately well the United
States has many more undocumented people
there's a very large illegal or
unauthorized population in the United
States that's definitely the case and
once you take those people out because
they can never become citizens that Gap
diminishes a little bit the type of
immigrants and the origins of those
immigrants are different in the two
countries and we can account for that as
well and I've done statistical analyses
that look at that as well but I would
suggest and in fact I would argue quite
strongly that even if you take these
things into account you're still going
to find a difference where immigrants in
Canada over the last 10 to 20 years are
much more likely to take out Canadian
citizenship than American citizenship
and this really speaks that I think the
answer to the question of identity and
who we are in the Canadian context
citizenship is very very
important um I've already said my
punchline public policy matters let me
tell you why it matters let me tell you
why I think public policy
matters if you talk to immigrants and I
did 151 in-depth interviews with people
both in the Boston area and Toronto talk
to ordinary immigrants talk to community
leaders talk to some government folk um
if you talk to people especially
immigrants how they became citizens
unless they're very highly educated have
really a good grasp of English Etc
they're going to tell you a story of
citizenship that is related to their
social networks the people they know
their Community organizations the ethnic
media that they might listen to or watch
sometimes fundamentally integration into
a society is about the social
connections we have and you know this is
a theme that's very much part of the
sear group that I'm in which is social
interactions identity and
well-being those social interactions and
it can be with organizations it can be
with Community leaders churches
religious organizations Etc they
facilitate that process of citizenship
and so I'm going to to give you some
examples of that in a second that
infrastructure the supportive
infrastructure of community
organizations is fundamentally helped
Along by things such as settlement
policy integration policy
multiculturalism
policies so the policy
infrastructure provides a foundation
upon which immigrant communities can
mobilize themselves they can do their
own things they do their own stuff but
especially for immigrant communities
that might not have the same resources
might not come with a lot of financial
Capital might not come with a lot of
Education because where they came from
they didn't really have the opportunity
to go very far they really need sort of
this seed money let's say um to help
them get integrated and also get on the
path of citizenship and then finally the
final point I'd like to make is that
public policy it's important for
instrumental reasons having a room
available for people to meet so that
they can talk about something in the
local library is fundamentally important
for helping this process along but it's
also the symbolic Notions behind
policies and this is really difficult
for a researcher to get her fingers on
right you talk to people oh the
symbolism is really important and
everyone's like yeah you give me a
regression statistic to really show me
that symbolism is important um and I can
tell you it's hard to convince people um
but based on the interviews I've done
the policies in place obviously do
things they give money they build you
know they do technical things they set
up regulations but those policies also
in the lines of people represent things
and if you want additional evidence
Beyond The Immigrant case just think of
that first or the second statistic I
showed you about Healthcare you know who
would have thought that someone's
identity as a Canadian would be linked
to whether you have health insurance or
not but clearly that is the case in
Canada so policies carry these identity
components with them which then builds
this bundle of
citizenship so I just want to give you
some flavor of this argument I could
talk for hours and hours and I warned
the sea far people that I probably would
if I wasn't r
um but I want to give you a sense of
what I argued in terms of the social
process of gaining citizenship so this
is based on an interview I did with a
Vietnamese American um he had not had an
opportunity to finish High School living
in the Boston area and I asked him you
know how did you become a citizen his
English was not very good I had to use
an a translator to do this interview and
he responded to me you know I I also
took a course in Chinatown I had to pay
there were a mix of people in the class
my friends who had already uh taken the
course told me about it um so you know
he was trying to become a citizen uh
needed some help to help him along the
process to fill out the form to make
sure he had enough English to pass the
English test for the citizenship exam
and so he asked his friends they told
him to take this course he took the
course that helped him along here's an
example from Toronto this is a a woman
of Portuguese Canadian woman who um also
did not have the opportunity to finish
High School in the azors before she came
to uh Toronto um and when I asked her
about her process she said well Manuel
uh it was another Portuguese uh Canadian
he's the one who taught us to get the
papers he applied for a supplement from
the government to pay him to teach us
about the politics to become a citizen
not just me lots of Portuguese so a
similar story of I need some help to get
this done I was you know helped along
someone taught us how to do it there's a
you know Civics exam that you have to do
there's some questions you have to
answer it helps helps a lot when someone
is holding your hand and sort of you
know teaching you quizzing you on these
things one key difference of course
between these quotes is that the
gentleman in the United States had to
pay for his classes in the case that I
me point out here these courses were
subsidized by government and so Tilla
did not have to really pay for them this
is a story that was repeated frequently
through the interviews that in the US
it's much more a Grassroots you have to
help each other get ahead kind of
strategy um there is some support
there's some great community- based
organizations doing work in the Boston
area but it was just less prevalent than
you'd have in a place like
Toronto that's true all right the other
thing the symbolism so I don't have
statistics but let me give you some
examples of why I think it really really
matters I interviewed Doris Meisner who
was the um commissioner for the
Immigration and Naturalization Service
when that still existed under the
Clinton administration she is probably
one of the ins Commissioners who were
most dedicated to citizenship she wanted
to put the N back in ins she was going
to put naturalization at the Forefront
it didn't work out that way she actually
started the uh increase in the border
control in the United States and was the
the person to actually put a lot of
money onto border control in this in the
southern border and when she reflected
back on her time as an ins commissioner
she said the dominant culture of the
agency is rooted in a view of
immigration as a source of security and
law enforcement vulnerability more than
of continued nation
building and I would argue this
interview was done uh before um ins
moved into the Department of Homeland
Security but currently in the United
States immigration and naturalization
services are within the Department of
Homeland Security and just by the name
of that agency you can imagine that that
hasn't really changed in the Canadian
case I interviewed some senior officials
at citizenship and immigration um I took
a sort of standard American line and
said why are using taxpayer dollars to
do all of this citizenship
stuff and uh the woman I spoke to got
quite upset with me um and said why
would we not encourage citizenship we
say everyone belongs that we believe in
diversity when we promote citizenship
let's be clear it talks about applying
yes but at its beginning it's about
integration one of the things I found
remarkable about this is that it rep it
represents an ethos towards not just
getting immigrants through the
administrative procedure of becoming
Canadian citizens and being able to have
a passport but it reflects Ed at least
in this woman's case and in some other
people's case when I interviewed them a
bigger vision of what they thought their
role was even if they were civil
servants this was not uh this was not
someone who was political this was
someone is a senior civil servant um in
Ottawa and this kind of attitude
immigrants get this they understand
what's going on um so with an interview
that I did with a Portuguese American
woman who was low income in uh the
Boston area she was complaining about
rents and she said but they the
government don't know how it is you
can't say Sir Sir send the people that
care about the immigrants because they
are the people who can't speak up there
is nowhere to complain to and we can't
complain so very much a feeling of being
shut
out in this other case um Joe was a
really interesting person because he had
deep attachments to Portugal and he
actually held both Canadian and American
citizenship um and I asked him well you
know who are you I guess I asked him who
are you um you know what are you and he
said I'm Canadian Adan and I said well
why are you Canadian why not these other
things and he said well I like the way
the government runs things I guess the
great support the multiculture stuff uh
the social assistance we pay a lot of
tax that's true uh but the great concern
of government the help for the citizens
themselves and so he felt much more
included um in government and in the
citizenry so when you know you can
imagine Joe having to answer this
question about do you feel you belong
and he would be one of those nine out of
10 residents of Canada who' say yeah you
know I do feel like I
along um this is I don't know if this is
important this is sort of a fancy
conceptual map for academics about what
I just said um it's not even that fancy
really um but you know basically the
argument is that government policy
provides both material resources but
also symbolic resources that they
communicate and give to mainstream
actors doesn't have to be immigrant
communities can be any you know lots of
other people um it affects ordinary
immigrants and their sense of belonging
and it affects ethnic organizations and
Community leaders and these groups then
can mobilize around some of these issues
and then of course they affect
government in turn I want to end with
two slides because I know my time is
running out why does citizenship matter
remember how I started with Angela
Merkel and Germany Etc I just did a new
paper that we're just sending out for
academic review where we looked at the
European Social Survey and we basically
divided countries in Europe between
countries that are open in terms of
citizenship and have embraced diversity
policies Multicultural policies versus
those who have not and so let's see if
multiculturalism is really bad and
divisive um if you look at perceived
discrimination the unitary countries
those are countries that really try to
have a unitary notion of belonging
immigrants in those countries are more
likely to perceive discrimination so
they're more likely to see
discrimination Visa themselves compared
to the pluralist places the places that
have more diversity policies more open
citizenship and if you ask about
political trust trust in political
institutions trust in politicians the
ones who are in the more pluralist uh
societies are more likely to feel a
little bit it's more likely to feel
trust in those institutions and
politicians than the ones in the more
unitary Societies or the societies where
the notion of citizenship is very
unitary and really the last last one
because it's election day um I want to
share with you some data on the actual
incidents of foreign born individuals in
the House of Commons and the house of
representatives in the two countries and
the data I'm going to show you takes the
proportion of the house that is foreign
born and divides that by the proportion
of the general population that is
foreign born to create an index and then
we can just sort of see how immigrants
are the houses um first answer is not
very much when you would normally think
that number should be one right so if
there's 20% of immigrants in the general
population maybe there should be 20% of
immigrants in the house that's not the
case however Canada is not doing that
bad the US is not doing that good um and
I would argue that part of this is just
exactly the legal citizenship story I
just told you you can't run for office
if you're not a citizen so part of the
fact that there's so much citizenship in
the Canadian immigrant population really
helps this process but I was also argue
to get back to the very first point
public policy really matters in
constituting our identities and in the
Canadian case it's an identity that does
have important links to public public
policies not only multiculturalism but
things like healthcare national parks
Etc and then the answer to who we are is
we are citizenship thank you very
much thank you arene our next presenter
is Clyde herzman who holds the dubious
status of having been appointed to more
sefr programs than any other researcher
in the institute's history he's been a
member of four programs and when you see
him you'll see he's not 150 years old
he's an epidemiologist a world-renowned
expert on early childhood development
and a professor at the University of
British Columbia please welcome caude
herzman who will answer tonight's
question who are you by arguing that you
are what your genes experience Clyde
well good evening it's a a pleasure to
be here um you may think from the title
that I've got up here that this will be
you know a Now for Something Completely
Different but as I talk through my talk
you'll see the ways in which what I've
got to say and what Irene has said and
what Alex will say actually fit together
in a certain way my basic idea that I'm
here to put forward is that we
understand now an awful lot more about
how our DNA works than we ever
understood before and what we've come to
understand now is that our DNA our genes
are not some sort of a blueprint which
then go on to print us out as people and
to Simply determine what our lives are
going to look like instead the DNA is in
conversation with the environment where
we grow up live and learn and out of
that conversation back and forth come a
number of emergent properties and some
of these emergent properties such as our
cognitive development and our social and
emotional development are basic
capacities that go on to shape the
opportunity to create an identity of the
sort that we're here to think about
tonight now to give you an idea um this
slide here um shows you Southern Ontario
divided into uh a number of of
neighborhood areas and it's showing the
fraction of children as they transition
from preschool to school who are
vulnerable or behind where we'd like
them to be on either their physical
their social emotional or their language
and cognitive development this is based
on a program that we've developed here
in Canada that is now covering most of
the country and it is populationbased
data now I know that it's very hard to
read this and I don't want you to read
it what I want you to recognize though
is that as you go from the green
neighborhoods to the brown neighborhoods
the fraction of children who reach
school age behind where we'd like them
to be on one or more of those domains of
development goes up 17 fold so the
lowest vulnerability neighborhood in
Ontario between about four and 5% of the
children are behind where we'd like them
to be on their development and in the
highest vulnerability areas it's running
65 to 70% so so that in a modern society
like ours and it's similar in other
parts of Canada by the time kids reach
school age the qualities of their early
experience have been such that what
ought to be no more than 10% of kids
being vulnerable has spread out to this
point where we have a 17-fold variation
in the vulnerabilities and kids
development that form the basic building
blocks upon which we can create an
identity now the reason that this occurs
early on in life has got to do with the
fact that there is a very dense network
of sensitive periods in brain and
biological development early on and as
I'm speaking a number of these
competencies are being laid out on this
graph where the gray part of the graph
divides into the lighter uh whitish
color at the transition to school age
and so what you can see is starting at
age zero going up towards the beginning
of school there's a dense network of
competencies that are emerging in early
life when we say that there are
sensitive periods in brain and
biological development what we're saying
is these are periods where exuberant
growth occurs and brain cell to brain
cell connections as a result largely of
the quality of environmental experience
that you get during that period of time
so sensitivity means sensitivity to the
environments in which you grow up live
and learn some of the things that occur
here are fundamental to Identity so you
see the white line showing Vision there
well what's going on on during the
sensitive period in in Vision
development is partly the opportunity to
recognize other human beings as the same
species in other words that basic
imprinting that allows you to know that
you in fact belong to the human race as
it were and that you aren't something
else similarly connections are starting
to be made between the visual systems
and deep structures in the midbrain uh
of our of our brain such as the mdala
and the locus celus which are centers of
the got to do with affiliation and
attachment in other words we get to that
point where if we've if we've been lucky
we start to recognize that the smile
means that we belong and the frown means
that something's going wrong and that we
belong certain places and that we are
not alien one way or another so the
sensitive periods in visual Pathways and
the things they connect to are
fundamental to the sense of belonging
and if you get that a consistent set of
human faces up close at the human focal
length of 13 in or so uh early on in
life you get it and if you don't you
don't and when you don't that means that
there are barriers to you creating a
constructive identity based on those
very very deep kind of things similarly
in terms of things like emotional
control it is in the early years that
the opportunity to develop verbal
negotiation skills instead of physical
aggression emerges and that of course
has a huge amount to do with whether or
not your identity as it emerges is a one
that is harmonious or one that is
oppositional one way or another thirdly
language has a sensitive period
throughout the early years and in this
period of time children's development of
receptive language what they understand
an expressive language what they can say
goes up pretty much as a straight dose
response with the number of words and
the variety of words that are spoken
directly to them per unit time so that
over the first 5 years of life across
North America we have a 30 million word
gap which is to say that the child who's
had the most language spoken to them in
the first 5 years of their life have had
accumulation of 30 million more words
spoken to them than the child who's
heard the least and with that difference
goes the ability to understand and to
express and with the ability to
understand and express goes the capacity
to form concepts of the self and others
and then finally by age three and four
what's starting to happen is early
experience is starting to shape our
executive functions in other words what
we focus on how we interpret it how we
make decisions and so forth such that
children who have grown up in chaotic
threatening unpredictable environments
tend to develop executive function
system that are hyperaroused but have
difficulty with focused attention
whereas children who grow up in
environments which are calmer and more
predictable and safer
have an easier time mounting a focused
attention response and what that means
is that they have an easier time
developing in a knowledge oriented world
a world which asks us to engage in
focused attention uh sorts of tasks and
so by the time kids reach school age a
whole series of things have occurred
which are either capacities or
incapacities that are boundary
conditions for developing an identity in
our society
now after that happens we have evidence
not so much from questions of identity
formation but from other areas that show
the ways in which these things ped uh
persist throughout the life course and
so by the end of the um second decade of
life things like School failure unwanted
teenage pregnancy and criminality are
influenced independently by what has
happened early on in life independent of
the influences that come thereafter by
the third and fourth Decades of life
things like obesity elevated blood
pressure and depression have an
independent influence from the early
years other things matter after the
early years but the early years effect
effect can still be seen by the fifth
and sixth decade of life you can see the
influence of the early years on things
like heart disease diabetes and other
chronic diseases and by uh later in life
you can see premature aging and memory
loss being associated with the early
years as well as things later on and I
have a note to my myself now that I'm
approaching the end of the sixth decade
of life to uh re-edit this
Slide the point I'm trying to make is
that what happens in the early years
continues to have influences throughout
the life course so when it comes to
matters of identity that we're here to
talk about tonight we are interested
then in the way in which these early
shaping factors can persistently uh
influence identity throughout the life
course
now one of the things that we've been
doing this is very much the work of the
Canadian Institute for advanced research
is working on a concept called
biological embedding trying to
understand the ways in which systematic
differences in the experiences that
people have in different walks of life
actually gets under the skin and scalp
and
influences our Behavior our organ
systems our cells and right down to the
level of the expression of genes in ways
that then go on to influence our health
well-being learning and behavior Across
the Life Course and so the concept is
the biological embedding of social
experience and the metaphor is
archaeology because we're talking about
something that goes from superficial to
something that goes very deep so at the
what I've been calling the shallow end
of the archaeology at the the uh whole
person and at the organ system uh level
um what we've been interested in
particularly are those systems that
actually carry on a two-way conversation
with the outside world so I talked
earlier on about the affiliate of
structures in the midbrain we have the
stress response pathway such as the
hypothalamic pituitary adrenal access we
have the prefrontal cortex and executive
function and if we put these systems
together what we have are the things
that allow you
to feel like you belong or are alienated
the things that allow you to feel
stressed or not the things that have got
to do with the way in which you judge
things of in the of the kind of variety
that iene spoke about in her
presentation so in fact at the shallow
archaeology level what we have is in
effect an identity system a series of
structures within the brain in
particular that work together to create
the neurobiological conditions for an
identity to occur and that's very
important that that be in a sense the
place where you can see the strongest
impact of the social environment
operating on the developing
human and so this is one example and
this is an example that can be tied
right back to that original map because
what it's got to do with here is
children from relatively privileged
environments who are also in this case
in low vulnerability areas so this would
be like those green areas on the map
before and the others are from lower
socioeconomic environments which in this
case happen to be high vulnerability or
the brown areas and so we've actually
gone out gotten children from these
areas put a shower cap on their head
with 128 leads and given them a task
that requires them to focus their
attention on something and then watch to
see what goes on inside of their heads
and the main thing to notice here is
that on the left when you average over
all of the kids from the green zone
there is a sharp notch in that black
line at the bottom at
0.3 uh seconds and on the right hand
side you don't see the same Notch that
Notch that you see there that's the
focus detention notch in other words by
the time these kids are in transition to
school we are seeing that their brains
function differently that in fact the
kids who are coming from the
environments of low vulnerability are
able much more easily to mount a focused
attention uh response than the kids from
the other side now you might be thinking
uhoh that sounds like genetic
determinism to me well it's not you
should know that in 3 months of of basic
a training program that they developed
at the University of Oregon you can
produce that notch on the right hand
side but you have to do it at the right
time in order to get it this is an
example though of what we mean by the
shallow archaeology seeing the way in
which the differences in the context in
which these kids have grown up has
penetrated to the level of the
functioning of their executive systems
and ways that could go on and shape
their identities later on in
life now beyond that we're now going to
talk about the Deep archaeology and in
particular we're going to introduce this
notion of epig Genesis and the
epigenetic influences of early
environments now before I Define this I
want to show you some interesting
pictures the first here are these two
butterflies they are they live in
subsaharan Africa the one on the right
as you can see is a bit bigger than the
one on the left it's blue the other
one's sort of orange the one on the
right has a tendency to sort of hide
behind leaves and live a rather uh dull
and sluggish life whereas the one on the
left floats around and flutters around
kind of like a Walt Disney
butterfly um so what here you are out on
Election night and here's this character
telling you about butterflies in Subs
Africa well the so what of this is that
until the genome could be read everybody
thought these were two completely
different butterflies turns out however
they are the same
butterfly genetically the same the
difference is that one of them was in
the cocon during the dry season the
other was in the Cocoon during the wet
season that's it and look at the
difference right
another example here are mice young mice
and adult mice and you can see by adult
age you've got the small brown one and
the absolutely obese yellow one these
also turn out to be identical twins
where they managed to manipulate it so
that they could be raised uh gestated in
different R uh mice mummies and be given
different maternal diets right so this
is entirely based on the difference in
maternal diet here between the little
brown and the obese and the obese Yow
both of these stories are stories about
epigenetics what they show basically is
the genes by themselves are not enough
to explain this remarkable variety that
what epigenetics is about is about
things that are persistent and heritable
in the sense that you can pass them as
cells divide over time and that change
the way in which our DNA functions but
doesn't actually involve
mutating the DNA or changing the DNA
sequence this is not about for instance
the threat from a nuclear power plant
exploding and us mutating and things
like that this has got to do with
processes biochemical processes whereby
the outside environment can speak to the
body set about biochemical C Cascades
that can add or remove chemicals that
sit on top of the DNA or surround the
DNA in various ways in ways that will
change whether or not genes Express
themselves and so as this slide suggests
across the life course we can have the
same genomes but we can have many
different epig genomes depending on our
experience particularly our experiened
early on in life now what is new about
this we've always known that every cell
in our body has the same DNA and yet a
brain cell is a brain cell and a blood
cell is a blood cell so at some point
point they have to differentiate people
have always understood that there was a
process of turning genes on and off so
that the cells can differentiate but
what we understand now is that it goes
Way Beyond the period of cell
differentiation throughout gestation
into the early years of life and
probably at a diminishing rate
throughout the
lifetime so epigen Genesis at work well
we have lots of evidence from how this
works now in other species other than
humans for instance in the rap the
world's most elegant work was done by
MOA shiff and Michael Mei two members of
The Experience based brain and
biological development program of sear
that showed that the degree to which rat
mummies lick and suckle their young
between day nine and 16 of their P Hood
believe it or not you call little baby
rats pups yeah who knew
um that that influences is the way in
which their hypothalamic adrenal access
pituitary adrenal access works on the
expression of cortisol which is one of
the stress hormones that influences
their capacity to learn uh new tasks
throughout their life course but that it
does so through an epigenetic mechanism
and they've managed to follow the entire
bioch chemical Cascade down identify the
gene that is being genes that are being
down regulated the genes that are being
upregulated as a result of increased
licking and suckling and moreover
they've sh know that in the female
babies who get high licking and suckling
they will go on and be high lickers and
sucklers in the Next Generation and low
will go on to be low so it is a
beautiful model of a nurturant
experience in this case licking and
suckling during a sensitive period in
development that has a lifelong impact
on learning in this case that goes
intergenerationally that operates
through an epigenetic effect in rees's
monkeys another of our uh fellows in the
EBD program uh has actually looked at
the difference in gene uh uh in
epigenetic uh marks as I'm going to call
them between uh rees's monkeys that are
raised by their mothers versus those
that are peered in other words they put
them together just with other baby
monkeys and they give them each a little
doll the substitute for the mothers and
there what they find is that of the
20,000 or so genes that can express
themselves in the rees's monkey DNA that
uh 4,000 of them or 20% of the uh genome
are epigenetically different between the
uh peer rear versus the the mother rear
right so you can see potentials for very
large effects so with that in place then
we've started to look at this in humans
and we've looked at it in relation to
stress and nutrition and lifestyle it's
been looked at in relation to identical
twins diverging over their lifetimes and
we've looked at it in relation into
things like maternal care and in my case
for instance what we've been interested
in whoops once again God ex there
looking backwards in time taking people
who we've been following from birth who
have now we followed 50 years into their
lives and looking
backwards uh to say what can we say
about the relationship between their
epigenetic status in midlife in relation
to their early years and we did that in
the 1958 British birth Cort so this is a
sample now of people who were born in
the the first week of March 1958 in
England Scotland and Wales that have
been followed ever since and at age 45
we collected white blood cells from
these individuals and we looked at the
whole genome to see how much systematic
differences we could see in relation to
certain things that went on early in
life the first thing that we discovered
was that 1252 gen in other words a full
6% of the genome was affected
epigenetically differently depending on
whether or not you were high
socioeconomic status child age 0 to 7 or
a low socioeconomic status so this is
socioeconomic status between 1958 to 65
being looked at in uh on samples
collected in
2003 basically so after 38 years Hang
Time 6% of the genome still different in
terms of the way it's expressing itself
the next one has got to do with whether
or not your mother smoked during
pregnancy this is collected back in 1957
58 when these kids were in utero and
there you can see nearly 800 genes
differentially expressed 45 years later
on as a uh following this difference in
exposure and then finally based on in
this case retrospective reports of abuse
physical verbal or sexual 1141 gen
differentially uh uh affected in terms
of methylation so what's starting to
happen now that we have these
technological capacities and the forms
of interdisciplinary groups where
epidemiologists like myself and cell
biologists of the sort that are brought
together under C programs can work
together we can start to understand how
profound these uh relationships are and
the degree to which early experiences
can land and stick on our DNA and change
the way they operate so the final one
I'm going to talk about is something
we've been doing recently and it's very
interesting because of the level of
precision we're starting to get to now
we're talking here about epigenetic
marks that we can see at age 15 in
relation to very very finely calibrated
data collection early on in life and to
make a long story short then what we
discovered was is that mothers but not
fathers stressors in the first 18 months
of Life are showing an epigenetic Mark
that persists well into the second
decade of Life on at least 100 different
genes yet in the preschool period when
the kids are 3 four and five it
gradually switches over so the father's
stressors are starting to get under the
the skin and influence children's
epigenetic marks more so than the
mothers it's a very very interesting way
that this has played out uh following
the kind of thing that if you wanted to
caricature it you could see where the
caricature would come from so we're in
early days with this work as you can see
and it's going to take years if not
decades to sort out how all of these
mechanisms go but what I'm here to leave
you with is the following idea that
basically there is a quality of identity
that feeds into what Irene has spoken
about and what Alex will speak about
which has got to do with an emergent
property of how genes are basically in
conversation with the environment at all
levels so there is the individual
developing child in the middle middle as
you can imagine who is surrounded in a
certain way by the family but these
broader
environments are playing into the
resources and the opportunities that are
brought to bear on that child and those
things have the chance of getting under
the skin and influencing who we are and
who we become thanks for
listening
you're beginning to get I hope a sense
of what some of us who love sear love
sear love about sear and that is that um
what looks like a single question is
actually many questions and what looks
like something that you would answer if
the top of your head with a few words
actually repays a lot more attention and
has much more texture and and uh ability
to engage our thought than you would
have thought at the beginning and I'd
like to introduce Alex Haslam who is our
next presenter who has yet another way
to think about the question of identity
when it comes to who are you he would
contend that you are the groups that you
belong to Alex is a social psychologist
he's based at the University of exor in
England and he is an innovator in
studying the relationship between
individual identity and group identities
please welcome Alex hin
thank you very much indeed for coming
and thank you very much for your support
for sea I can assure you speaking on
behalf of all of the uh fellows of the
various programs we very much appreciate
it and our goal is to translate your
support into real positive change not
just in the scientific Community but in
society as a whole and I think uh I'm
very pleased that tonight's event is not
a competition because I think everything
that Irene has said and everything that
Clyde has said is true and what I want
to do is engage in a conversation with
them and with you by filling out this
story I think in an interesting Way by
looking at the way in which identity is
dictated by the groups that we belong to
so that the nature of the self if you
like is if you like more complex than
they suggested but actually I think if
you and I'm sure you are listening I can
hear you're listening closely you will
see points of contact between what I
what they have said and what I am going
to say let's just start by thinking
about if I said to you who are you if we
met out there who are you say well
that's a stupid question I'm John I'm
Peter or I'm Mary or whatever I'm cath
okay that indeed is the way that most
people think about identity you know who
am I well I'm an individual I'm Alex or
I'm Irene or I'm Clyde and that surely
then the nature of identity is bound up
in our individual experiences our sense
of ourselves as I our unique experiences
our
uh
idiosyn idiosyncratic characteristics
traits qualities and so on experiences
so in that sense perhaps the true self
is our personal if you like our personal
self bound up in our personal identity I
and me so again we have if you like if
you think about Irene Clyde and myself
we're different we have nothing in
common we have separate distinct
identities clearly discernable and
should not not to be in any sense uh
confused well let's just have a kind of
a look at that a kind of so if you like
if you take that idea it surely follows
that if I really want to understand
someone's identity and if I wanted to
understand my own identity what I would
need to do is kind of R remove myself
from social contact and kind of go
deeper and deeper into that personal
self and this is a little experiment
that a BBC um journalist conducted
recently and his book was published just
a few months ago and this journalist
partly I guess for his own person
reasons but also out of a sort of
peculiar scientific curiosity went to
live as a Hermit in in the mountains of
mid Wales and what did he find this is
his what he said in his this book what I
found was not what you might expect you
might s think that such protracted
Solitude would lead to introspection to
Growing self-awareness but not for me
what happened was that I began to forget
myself my focus shifted almost entirely
outwards it was as if we gain our sense
of self from our interaction with other
people alone there was no need for
identity for self-de so actually going
deeper and deeper into the personal self
becoming more of an eye actually you
lose contact with identity so let's now
start to explore if you like the
alternative thesis the idea that maybe
identity is social perhaps who we are is
not as us I as the unique me but perhaps
it's defined by our group memberships if
if you're in this room perhaps you think
of yourself as Canadians I think Irene's
given some compelling evidence to that
effect probably at least nine out of 10
suspect it's higher in this room or as
students or as blue jay fans or as seat
bar researchers so perhaps the true self
is social in that way and myself and my
colleagues many of whom are on this
program but our views as they've kind of
evolved as L of the scientific debate
that the others have talked about have
come to the view that the self is a
social category and that depending on
context yes we can Define ourselves as
individuals in terms of our personal
identity as I and me we certainly do
have that distinct identity I can tell
that I am not Clyde I hope and he can
tell he's not me and so on maybe even
more of an issue in the case of ir okay
that we that we want to know that we're
different indeed we clearly are but at
the same time we can Define our sense of
self in terms of shared group
memberships it's not an accident that we
have the words we and us in our
vocabulary they reflect true and
authentic aspects of sense of true and
authentic aspects of self our capacity
to Define ourselves collectively so and
of course if You' like if you think
about social identity then the question
well becomes well Which social
identities do we find us other in terms
of which group memberships matter to us
so Clyde and Irene and ourselves could
Define ourselves in terms of a common
identity as scientists or as seifa
researchers but we could also Define
ourselves in terms of distinct
identities based on nationality based on
our gender or for example based on the
particular CA research groups that we're
a part of and what you see there is that
as different identities become Salient
are if you like the the who we feel
close to and who we identify with
changes in predictable and meaningful
ways and I'm going to suggest that to
that that has profound implications for
the kind of behavior that we would
manifest in the contexts that go along
with those identities so the question
then is when do particular identities
become Salient and again you might think
that's a a simple question actually it's
peculiarly complicated in if I were to
answer it in a single sentence the
answer as to when we Define ourselves in
terms of particular identity is when it
makes sense to do so in terms of the
present context the context the
situations environments in which we find
ourselves and our prior experience as a
function of previous context in which
the self has been expressed I've said
that self is a category a social
category what we know about categories
is that they become Salient they become
meaningful as an interactive product of
fit when they fit the situation and when
they're accessible when if you like
we've had a history of using those
categories in the past so what that
means in the case of a self category a
social a self social category a sense of
asness for example as Canadian you're
more likely to Define yourself as
Canadian if you're watching uh Canada
play sports and the Olympics okay that
was a point I think Irene made there are
contexts in which um we are comparing
ourselves I'm not a Canadian but I like
to think I am sometimes because it makes
me feel good okay so
we think of ourselves as Canadian in
contrast to other groups we may
competing with or we feel Superior to in
fact probably most definitely are
superior to in the case of Americans
okay so so we um we again that
comparative context makes that identity
Salient if the sport in some sense or
the activity is typical of that identity
so you're more likely to feel Canadian
if you're watching Ice Hockey than if
you're watching a field hockey for A's
sake or if you're watching tennis or
something like that and also if um being
Canadian has meant something to you in
the past so what happens then is that
fit the fit and accessibility of a
particular identity go together to make
a particular identity as Canadian as all
these other things sent in a particular
context if that if you like that sence
is enacted over a long period of time so
and becomes meaningful then what happens
actually in the same the ways that
actually both Irene and Clyde suggested
that identity is caring forward and so
you get some sense of social identity
continuity so you get a if you like you
don't get a disjunct or a sort of
schizophrenic Narrative of the self you
get you experience our sense of self in
a fluid flowing meaningful way you get
social identity continuity and then that
feeds into social identification so that
the social identities if for example
this is a new identity for you as being
a supporter of CA or someone who in CA
then that will then become a resource
that you can draw upon in other contexts
so whereas this might be the first time
you've acted in those ways in the future
then it's going to be um more likely
that you will have that as a resource
and that your behavior will be
determined by that group membership okay
so that's if you like something about
the mechanics of how identity becomes
say how it becomes psychologically
operative but the other question you
might want to know is well okay but why
do we need researchers to answer those
questions does this really matter in any
sense and of course I think all of us
would say yes it matters very
profoundly the if you like the simple
reason why it matters is because to the
extent that a shared social identity a
sense of usess becomes salent it has
important implications for
organizational behavior what are those
uh consequences well when a shared
identity as I we talking a lot about
being Canadian identity as Canadian for
example becomes s then we tend to see
ourselves as similar to other members of
that category of that group so if you
had all just if you happened to have
bumped into each other on the on the
Metro on the way here you wouldn't have
felt that you had anything in common
with the person sitting next to you but
now that you're in this room and your
relationship to that other person is
defined by this shared identity you you
feel that sense of of commonality you
feel closer to them you're more likely
to listen to them and think they have
something interesting to say to you and
then by the same token they're more
likely to think that you have something
interesting to say to them so in that
sense you're more likely to engage in
mutual influence to the extent that you
share identity and also to the extent
that we Define ourselves as a collective
we're more likely to come together and
work together to achieve Collective
goals that's exactly what Irene was
talking about if we share an identity as
Canadian citizens we more likely to
participate in Acts of citizenship that
Propel Canada forward rather than say
that's got nothing to do with me so I
don't want to be a part part of it and
the Really profound point then is that
actually social identity is what makes
organizational organizational life and
organization as a as a as a process
possible without social identity without
that sense of usance we couldn't engage
in the collaborative activities that if
you like Propel Society forward now
again you all work in your organizations
what I would say is Central to the
ability of those organizations to work
work is a sense of shared identity both
at the superordinate organizational
level but perhaps at subgroup levels too
and indeed some other work that we've
recently done a book that I and
colleagues have recently published makes
the point that leadership as a process
is entirely contingent upon shared
identity and we show that groups that
don't have shared identity cannot have
the experience of leadership something
fundamental to Human Society again I say
fundamental does that really matter is
this a matter of life and death yes it
is okay let's ask a question you get
some epidemiologists like Clyde here and
you say well I'll come to this second
I'm going to say the bottom the line I'm
coming to is that actually social
identities make us human and that they
make life worth living so again what's
the epidemiological data about threats
to health if you take those things and I
ask you which of those is the most
dangerous activity you could engage in
the most dangerous condition you could
find yourself in smoking a lack of
exercise being obese having a genetic
predisposition to illness having a poor
diet or being socially isolated it's
actually not physical isolation it's a
sense of psychological isolation well if
you read the blur that goes with this
talk and perhaps if you thought more
generally about where this is going
you'd know that actually the re the
biggest threat to health that
individuals face throughout the lifespan
is social isolation that's the biggest
killer that's out there one of the
reasons we don't focus on on the
consequences of social isolation is you
can't cure it with a drug so drug
companies can't make a lot of money out
of if you like curing dealing with that
particular problem actually that's a
problem we have to deal with ourselves
that's some of you will know that
reference there that's Ellena rcky and
indeed one of the great problems of
contemporary Society is that we have too
many lonely people in it okay and again
part of the one of arm of the program
that I is really addressing issues of
social integration the way Irene
suggested and looking at the way in
which that has profound effects on
health so actually if you look in the
data you'll see there are Health
consequences of the types of things that
I read and obviously Clyde were talking
about again here's some practical data
from a study that we conducted with
stroke patients in the southwest of
England was conducted with my colleague
Kath husand she's also my wife that um
um in the southwest she's here as well
tonight if you want ask her about her we
are we looked at um patients or who had
had a stroke and we looked at lots and
lots of different things things we
looked at whether people had belonged to
groups before their stroke whether they
had cognitive difficulties language
executive function difficulties after
their stroke and whether they still
belonged to their groups after their
stroke what you see is of as you might
expect that actually if you belong to
groups before your stroke that's a big
predictor of Life satisfaction after
your stroke and similar if you have
cognitive difficulties that's also a big
predictor there's a big numbers in fact
about equal in fact not different so of
course if you have language difficulties
your life is going to be less positive
than it was prior to the stroke but
what's really interesting too is that
those two things predict Your Capacity
to maintain group memberships after the
stroke so if you belong to a lot of
groups before your stroke it's likely
you'll be belong to more groups
afterwards if you have cognitive
difficulties it's less likely that
you'll be be able to maintain group
memberships and what you see and you can
do fancy statistical analysis is that
you show that all of the power in this
analysis comes from the fact that the
really big predictor of well-being after
a stroke is whether you can maintain
valued group membership so if you
experience a sense of social identity
loss that you can't live out a social
life that was really important to you
prior to stroke then your health is
seriously compromised and it's because
things like cognitive deficit impinge
upon that that they are really important
okay
so if you like then the question okay
that's maybe a slightly depressing story
in some sense so the question is and
again the question myself and my
colleagues in CA in our group really
address very fundamentally is well can
we do anything about that if a sense of
identity loss is Con compromise health
and well-being can we do anything to
create a sense of shared identity that
will feed into positive Health outcomes
and again to do this we've done this in
a range of vulnerable populations but
what if you look across the lifespan and
you look at the other end of the spect
from the one that Clyde was talking
about when in their lives do people are
they most likely to experience profound
identity loss and it's very much towards
the end of people's lives when they
retire and in particular if they have to
move into a care facility like a
residential care home and that was who
we uh looked at in this study this was a
situation where in the the care homes
that we're doing actually next week
we're going off with a support of CA to
run one of these studies in kitchen but
this is based on one we've done pre
previously we were looking at a a care
home where the Care staff were worried
that a lot of the residents have become
very isolated and they weren't using
communal facilities in particular they
weren't using the lounges in the wings
where their own rooms were located so
what the staff had suggested was that
they had a a plan to kind of redecorate
the loues because they become AI so on
and maybe by redecorating and freshening
them up they would enhance the you know
make just make people feel more positive
about that envirment more likely to use
those facilities and of course this sort
of thing doesn't just go on in Care
Homes it goes on in organizations it
goes on in public spaces and so on just
by freshening them up maybe people will
come and use them and feel better and so
on so in this study to kind of explore
that idea but to if you like Infuse it
with some of these understandings that
we have from some of our work and some
of our colleagues we have a design yeah
one we had a control condition in a care
home where two Wings had no redecoration
whatsoever that was a kind of a baseline
we had another Wing in which the
residents moved into that ring and it
was beautifully redecorated uh with to
the highest possible standard on the
basis of decisions that had been made by
the staff on the basis of their PR
experience but the residents were not
involved in those decisions and in the
third conditions what we did the third
condition we got Wings involved as
groups in the process of making
decisions about uh the decor in those
new wings
okay and our view was there that if we
could involve people as a group and
create a social identity around that
activity then maybe that would have the
kind of positive outcomes and perhaps
only under those conditions that the
Care staff wanted to see in their
residence actually if I had a bit more
time and I know it's very precious I'd
show you a video of this but hopefully
you might go on the website so you can
see it afterwards this was actually this
I should say to this study was filmed by
the BBC and it was part of a documentary
on This research this is what we uh
this is a social identification in the
Baseline condition over time you don't
see any difference and the same is true
in the control in the control condition
where the decisions were made for the
residents where they're empowered though
as you would predict the residents
started to feel connected to the other
residents they felt that the person in
the room next door to them was no longer
a stranger and the staff the same so
they felt more part of the community how
did that affect on their life
satisfaction well as you'd expect in the
Baseline condition in the control
conditions there wasn't much change but
in the empowered condition where they
come together as a group you got a
massive increase in life satisfaction
very and that was associated with
significant drops in depression clinical
depression it was also associated with
cognitive functioning Kath who does work
in this as a cognitive neuropsychologist
was assessing their ability to perform
cognitive executive tasks well in the
Baseline condition over time as you see
in most Camp you actually see some
deterioration in the control condition
that was somewhat arrested but there was
only a marginal increase but in the
empowered condition what you see is that
being involved in a group feeling part
of the community if you like infused
people with a motivation to actually
engage and what we saw was particularly
increases in memory and language
functioning if you like aspects of
cognitive functioning that are strictly
motivational okay so people were
motivated to engage and again part of I
think some of the research that Clyde
does is is suggesting that if you create
an intelligent community in which people
engage then you can enhance their their
cognitive performance very more
generally and what we're showing is that
applies throughout the lifespan I said
this was a study about social isolation
if you look at the uh control conditions
what you see is that overtime people
were not more likely to use their
lounges in fact after decoration they
were less likely to use their lounges
why because they didn't recognize them
anymore they were foreign places they
come in what and one woman expressed
complete surprise she thought she'd
being moved into another home being
redecorated no yeah that's right I have
to say it's not quite that funny when
you see it okay and um the uh but
amongst those people who've been
involved in the process of change what
you see is a massive increase in fact a
three-fold increase in that use of space
so again the cure for social isolation
isn't just to create better environments
it's to engage people as as collectives
in the process of transforming those
environments so creating meaningful
social groups builds a sense of shared
identity and thereby promotes
intellectual and physical engagement and
obviously that's a point that applies in
this kind of domain but I think it
speaks very much to the points that both
Irene and Clyde were making and actually
that out of this kind of work
collaboratively there's a a book that
Kath and I but others our cifr
colleagues have contributed to and what
we talk about this is that the social
cure and this is not an alternative
we're not saying you don't need drugs
anymore but what we're saying is we need
to invest more energy in understanding
the social determinance of health and
driving developments that will help us
to deliver Alternative forms of cure
that are evidentially based and based on
really high quality uh understanding and
high quality science last two slides
very quickly then to wrap it all up and
again I think this again speaks to the
points that uh the others have made
humans are social animals again if you
watch being here in this room is a
profound kind of experience you are here
you live it you can feel it if you were
watch it later on on on the webcast I
think you'll be these are fantastic
technicians doing the filming by the way
but it will be sort of lifeless in a
particular I hope it isn't by the way if
you're watching okay but it will be in a
particular sense it will it's better to
be here it's better to be next to and
hear the laughter of the person next to
you to feel them to have a little talk
to them about it the great thing about C
course is it creates these kind of
communities it creates meaningful social
identities that are propelling Canadian
and World science forward but again that
speaks to the fact that science like
every other human activity is profoundly
social and that social life is a source
of pleasure but it's not just a source
of pleasure it also gives our lives
purpose and it gives them meaning and
it's also a basis fundamentally for our
sense of self so yes going back to the
point that I started yes we are everyone
in this room is unique but actually I
never I never say paradoxic because I
don't I think there very few true
paradoxes this is not a paradox but
actually that's a reflection of the
uniqueness of the social spaces that we
occupy we all belong to a constellation
of different groups that give us each a
different pattern or a different fabric
to our self but actually our
individuality is the most profound
expression of uh sociality and again the
final then par I said I never used the
word paradoxically there I'm okay
paradoxically then our individuality
arises precisely because so many groups
are important for who and what we are
and final point I'd make is that to
understand the self then we should not
turn inwards and if you like down the
microscope and so on and look deeper and
deeper into our genetics or independent
of the society from which we become it's
exactly what Clyde I think is saying
that actually to understand the self we
need to turn towards Society not away
from it now that might seem like a
rather you know not a significant point
I hope I've convinced you that it's a
profound point that has a a range of
implications I think that is a message
that's relevant to this talk but it's a
message I think that's relevant to
science and to society individual
scientists need communities and I think
those communities need individual
scientists and it's the if you like the
ability of structures political and
intellectual to fuse those things and to
harness the power of the individual in
creative ways that again I think is
fundamental to human progress and human
sociality I'd like to end just by
thanking ca for doing precisely that
creating a community in which I think
each of us as individual scientists can
feel better and that we can feel we can
make a real difference because our
energies are fused with those of our
colleagues and that they've created a
wonderful audience yourselves who if you
like provide us with the ultimate test
for ideas and the ultimate motivation
thank you very
much
uh so what we're going to do now is have
a little conversation with ourselves and
you're going to listen I hope and think
about what questions you'd like to ask
and then at the point at which it'll be
your turn to ask questions if you raise
your hand someone will magically appear
with a microphone and you'll get to ask
a question okay so um all of you have
heard from each other and um this is a
very our life moment because your
understandings support and and and
butress each other and one of the
reasons we wanted to have this event in
this way is to demonstrate that people
who come at a question from different
angles actually enrich your
understanding of the question and give
you a sense that much more isn't play
than you would have thought when you
first began and what I'd like to ask if
you're if you don't think it's too
personal is has your research on this
topic in any way affected your own sense
of
identity anybody want to try that one
there
okay well one of the things I have to
say is
that some of this stuff of understanding
the developmental capacities in relation
to the much more
evolved and uh if you'd like more
cerebral elements of identity that Alex
and and Irene were talking about has
given rise to me a kind of dualism that
I spend a lot of time thinking about the
person that I want to be as opposed to
the person that I end up being by
default in other words when I can feel
some fairly mid-brain
things some fairly stress response
pathway think kind of driving everything
and me reacting to it as opposed to
coming off of a place where I can in a
way kind of get beyond that and you know
see myself in in in in a broader world
so it's it's created a form of of
dualism for me a kind of a kind of a
tension there but it's it's a it's an
interesting kind of uh it's an
interesting kind of Consciousness that
there's days in which I wish I could get
away from it but there it
is I would you like to take this
question up a little bit or not sure
somewhat I think I'm going to reverse it
though it's more you know why am I if
you ask some of my colleagues at the
University of California Berkeley um
there's one or two who's like all Irene
thinks about is immigration it's
immigration immigration immigration like
this isn't there anything else that
exists in the world um and clearly it's
I think almost the other way around that
my Identity or or my experiences I
believe very strongly about what Clyde
and Alex have saying brought me on this
pathway so I was was um my my father was
a geologist I was born in Spain we lived
in Greece we lived in England they were
Dutch my first language was Dutch we
come to Canada I'm really young I was
three or four I hit montor because my
mom's like she has to learn English um I
learn English and you know that's a very
Cosmopolitan background at least up
until my four and then I spend my
formative years in Canada uh go through
the public school system go to McGill
get my bachelor's degree in political
science get a master's degree in
sociology go to Harvard for my PhD and I
have now been in the United States 15
years which is becoming a more and more
significant proportion of my total life
um and if you ask me what my identity is
it would still be Canadian first and
formost and I don't get it on certain
levels like I I truly don't get it
because if you add up the time I've
actually been in Canada it's getting to
be about half of my lifetime and so why
was that so imprinted on my brain and
maybe it was because it was at some
formative stage in my life um it was
definitely because my formative years in
K to 12 education were in Canada and so
these these contexts Etc but I also
really fundamentally believe that it has
to do with public policy and so I think
that my personal identity pathway has
brought me to this question but it also
places me in a really difficult
situation when I'm in the United States
because I'm not a US citizen and so here
I am the scholar of immigration who
thinks everyone should be participating
and becoming a
citizen and um I've had a few cases
where people have wanted to bring me to
Congress and talk about my research and
then I sort of whisper to them like not
an American they're like oh can't get
you to Congress too bad and it's it's
not it's not that my research doesn't
stand on its own my research stands on
its own but in the particularly
politically inflected topic of
immigration things can be used against
you in a lot of different ways so I've
heard that my research has actually
influenced American policy on some of
this stuff but it's been done by other
people who reference my research that's
interesting is
interesting now I know Alex you're much
too young to have spent any time in any
residential home but I'm wondering
whether um you also have had your
research affect your sense of identity
well I think I mean I think the
fundamental point is I I think that
being in sear has has created new
identities for me so so as a prior to
being part of the group I inan I think I
and my colleagues are Define ourselves
fairly narrowly as psychologists but
increasingly I become interested in
issues of Health as i' of illuminat I
didn't have that interest at all I'd
never done any research in Care Homes
I'd never done any research that indexed
Health constructs and similarly I I
worked with a lot of economists I didn't
know anything about economics so I think
as a scientist I think i' my orientation
to my own field has changed and my those
of people working in cognate areas has
changed but also I I I see that as
entirely positive but I think I've got
much kind of bigger imagination as a
result of that being fueled by the
imaginations of other people and and I'm
sure that's true for
everybody so um my my experience and
when I watch sear groups work together
and I have to say this is one of the
most wonderful things I get to do is I
get to walk into a room where a lot of
very very intelligent people are
struggling with a complicated question
and working together and sometimes I I
would swear that you can see
a mind melt going on of something bigger
than anybody's individual mind appearing
in the room Clyde knows this is so it
appears in the room sort of hovers over
the table um not literally but
metaphorically and you can see something
new being created not just a new idea
but a new way of thinking that is
um communicating itself to the whole
group and you could and if you're
someone like me watching from the
outside because I'm not a member of the
group you can also um see people's heads
start to nod as as they are all kind of
together coming to a new understanding
so in a way some of the things that that
Alex has been saying about um the
importance of social connectedness is
happens in these rooms of people working
together and I have to say these are not
necessarily comfortable places because
they're not simply reaffirming for each
other what they already think in fact
they're struggling to understand
something new that they don't understand
yet but it still has this very positive
sense of the creating some creating a
social group that's different from the
individuals in the room connected to
them but um also putting people in a new
space now I hope this isn't just my
sentimental notion of what it is that
happens in seafar groups that I watch
but is that a fair description I think
it is I mean if I I can answer Tex I
mean I think that's absolutely right I
and this is something I study as an
organizational psychologist is the
process of creativity and a lot of
people think that creativity is
something that vested in in individuals
as individuals it isn't it actually
takes particular group dynamics to
unlock creativity you've got a create
motivation to be creative and you've got
to create the audience that's receptive
to that creativity and the The Contours
of that are defined by shared identity
so there's in the organizational domain
there's a phenomenon called the not
invent invented here phenomen we don't
listen to other people when when they
are other when they're not part of self
so again I think part of the the success
of c and the conent groups that it
creates are that it creates uh identity
based or identity defined dialogue of a
completely novel form because it's
creating these new powerful identities
and I actually I I think that's true in
whatever domain you work and actually it
just underlines the point that I think
we're all making that actually identity
is Central to to to Social and
intellectual life in profound ways that
we haven't really fully understood and I
think so we do both live the science but
also try to understand it more and I
think we're only really just beginning
yes there's no question that that the
forums that the the sear programs take
in particularly the ones I've been part
of I know this are the basis on which
creativity could emerge and so for
instance in order to do the kind of work
we've been doing we've had to find ways
to merge between natural and social
sciences uh at a fairly high level so if
you think about that concept of
biological embed it's what would we
would call a consilience concept in
other words it is something that is
meant to be a bridge between the natural
and the social sciences and you only get
that when you have the right people in
the room together for a long enough time
to understand what each other's talking
about and to start to build those
bridges and so now where we're at with
this phenomenon of epigenetics we're at
the point of saying you know what
genetics is more a social science
then it is a natural science at this
point why because in order to understand
what is going to land and stick you have
to understand so much more about social
process some of you may have noticed
that when I put up the slide the there
was lots of associations you know in
terms of epigenetic marks between the
things I talked about and and and so
forth but that the mark of mother
smoking during pregnancy was weaker
than abuse which was weaker than
socioeconomic status now if you asked
the average bench scientist which way it
would go it would go the other way in
terms of what they would expect because
they would have a certain explanatory
Paradigm right but now we're in the
situation where we can put together
people like the two on my left and right
who have way better understanding about
how people actually function in
groups and then we can turn around and
say okay well how do we model these in
these models right so the idea of going
out and looking for the epigenetic
signature of alternate identities is the
sort of thing that would be advocated
for here and I'm prepared to bet A
month's salary that that will be a
larger signature than what a bunch of
bench scientists would imagine because
they will end up imagining well what
does HIV do what does you know this
toxin do or something like that they
will be thinking in a very very
different form right and what the sefar
programs have done is allowed to build
those bridges of consilience so that we
can not only daydream about these kind
of things and think we're nuts but we
can actually Express them and get on and
do the
work so I'm going to ask um just one
more question of each of you and it's
about what is the next research area or
the next question you were thinking
about that you would most like to have
an answer for the thing you would most
be excited to be able to answer I do you
think you have a sense of what that
might be well it's a good academic I'm
not going to give you one answer we
never give one answer to anything yeah
here my four five six wish list um two
things that I'm very interested in is
given you know what I talked about in
terms of the backlash against
multiculturalism um is that there's
clearly a lot of anxiety in all kinds of
societies about rapid demographic change
and it's because that rapid demographic
change bring other people in contact
with us
and I do it in the context of
international migration but you can
imagine all kinds of other moments in
time when rural people move to cities or
there were other kinds of major changes
you can imagine you know Hurricane
Katrina devastating New Orleans and so
the changes in the societies we live in
the context the neighborhoods we live in
um and often we're not allowed to talk
about how we don't like people for
cultural or racial or religious reasons
that's not politically correct in our
societies people do it but you're not
really supposed to um but a lot of the
anxiety is cultural or it's something
related to these people are other these
people are different and so one of the
conversations that I've I'd like to have
even more in the future with Alex who is
in the sear program that I'm at is what
are some of the techniques what are some
of the things that we can do that people
who normally would see each other as
completely other would actually we'd
actually be able to do something that
you have a connection and then you start
feeling you know maybe not say that
you're Canadian but that you feel a
member of your neighborhood or you feel
a member of this little area in space or
it doesn't even have to be physical
space maybe it be virtual world so one
of the things I'm really interested in
is how do we make those connections that
bridge this sense of otherness so that
we can actually feel cohesive and I have
lots of other projects but I'll leave it
at that that's a big enough one that's a
big one that's a big one Alex you want
to answer that question um I I mean I
think again part of the beauty of this
program actually and
I I I could answer give you a project
but won't because actually the real
beauty of CA is all my rest of my
academic life and Cassie and she'll say
the same thing we have to write grants
and we have to say what we're going to
do and we have to plot it out in minute
detail years and years ahead and we have
to justify we stick to that path and if
we deviate from it's a nightmare the
beauty about coming to se far is
actually I don't have to do that I can
just come and think and talk and go
where where where the flow takes me I
think that's actually how good science
gets done so I I have a few questions
but I know and I I I could want if I the
month salary I know that anything I say
will never be what I do because at the
end of the day it will be this beautiful
collaborative process it will take me
somewhere it be far more
interesting that
was would you like to answer that
question
okay you can say no I don't want to
answer that question no it's all right I
I you know it's it's not an easy
question I I feel I feel a lot like Alex
feels about that but I would say
thinking forward about the things that
I'm involved in there there's a number
of things that I'm really excited to
stick around for uh although my
presentation this time was very much
about things under the skin people may
be aware that I operate s to society so
if you want to say you know what I'd
really be excited for I'm going to give
two things right on the one hand in
terms of the direction that this work is
is going I really do want to stick
around long enough to understand if what
we think we're seeing is true which is
to say that the way in which social
experience influences The genome is not
so much that it goes for this specific
Gene Loi or that one or that one but
that instead it seems to shower The
genome with uh chemical changes in
effect that may be very large so that
there would be a signature of life is
going to be hard right so a number of
things you know uh that might have to do
with the quality of your early domestic
environment might give a broad
evolutionary signal that life is going
to be hard and that that will have all
sorts of different effects on a whole
range of different Gene loide way
Upstream that will then end up playing
out Downstream and we now have the
Technologies to be able to see that
whether or not this works as like a
shower nonspecific sort of evolutionary
showering signal as opposed to sort of a
very sort of surgically picking out this
Gene versus that Gene signal so that's
what I want to know at that end but the
other end people should know that one of
the things that I'm involved with is
monitoring the rights of the child
around the world and we've developed a
protocol for monitoring in particular
the rights in early childhood that 193
countries of the world have signed up
for and I want to stick around long
enough to figure out whether or not
really trying to find ways to get
countries to live up to their commitment
will actually have an effect on the
state of children's development uh in
those countries and we've put out a
protocol I give it a one in 50 chance of
getting funded at this point but within
5 years I think we'll get the money and
Away we'll go and uh that'll hopefully
keep me going yeah wonderful thank you
so um now is your turn and if anybody
would like to ask a question uh there's
somebody who needs a microne pH and
here's somebody who needs a microphone
so first that one and then here hello hi
John um guess my gosh someone I
recognized yeah I used to work for these
guys yes um uh perhaps it's because it's
election day and perhaps because I'm a
recovering politician but this question
comes to mind is it possible that
amongst the three of you you can produce
a kind of unified field Theory which
starts I think with Clyde
observation about
how social life affects uh outcomes um
for very young children I like the way
he let to rights you see but rights is
associated the other at the upper end
with it seems to me with citizenship and
and it's mediated in the middle by what
Alex does through groups so it seems to
me that the highest form is citizenship
because it's purposeful it assumes that
social institutions can be changed
assume some kind of normative behavior
and that we can actually improve
ourselves we don't have to be resigned
to some kind of Fate so I'm wondering if
the three of you could get together and
by the end of the evening produce a
unified field theory for
me who's going to take that one on well
I'm just going to say I think you you've
actually outlined the Godfree unified
field Theory right there I mean I think
that is how this fits together and I
think that that's it's really important
uh to think that way you know I mean as
as Alec was talking about what he was
talking about and showed the socially
isolated person and I'm sitting there
thinking about the
neurobiological uh phenomena that would
predispose towards more or less social
isolation just to give one example I
mean there's been this study it's a
beautifully done study it's very sad
study though uh done in Wisconsin by a
fellow by the name of Seth kollock where
they got children who' been removed from
their homes because of abuse basically
and kids who hadn't been and at age five
they put the little shower cap with
leads on it and showed them a series of
pictures of the same adult face starting
very smiling and welcoming and then a
little less Smiley and a little less
Smiley and a little more angry and a
little more Angry Etc so 10 faces across
a series of these things and waited to
see when the kid showed a fear response
to make a long story short what happens
is the kids who have grown up in those
environments where there's been
abuse they have a threshold shift so
they start seeing anger and something to
be afraid of in those faces after you're
about three or four faces along whereas
the other kids don't sh see any anger
until you're about seven or eight faces
along so you can imagine what that means
for the prospects of belonging right for
that first child
the majority of the face majority of the
faces looking at me right now would be
profoundly threatening right how does a
person like that belong in the sense
that Alec is talking about right I mean
it's a it's it's a profound question and
a very difficult question and at the
same time you know it's very interesting
when you know somebody like Irene goes
out and asks her questions you get
responses I mean the people I'm talking
about respond to her questions and I'd
like to know how they respond on I mean
do people who grow up in those kind of
world end up being predisposed to
Notions of citizenship that are about
self-denial and and and uh you know
affiliation let's say with with things
military or something like that I mean
can you start to see those kind of
differences emerging over time versus
those who feel themselves more part of
the softer elements of the community
would be wonderful to know those kind of
things right and those out of those
things we could validate the god- free
uh unified field Theory anybody else
want to add to or subtract from the
Godfree unified field Theory you know
one of the things that I find exciting I
think you're right that there there's
obvious links across us is that
sociologists are often blamed I guess
for not having any agency in our
theories right because the very purpose
of a sociologist is to tell you why the
reason you are the way you are has
nothing to do with you but it has
everything to do with the social
structures in which you're embedded and
so if you are a successful person who
has had a rich life made a lot of money
Etc has nothing to do with you has
everything to do with your upbringing
and your social structure and your
position Etc and the problem of course
is that you don't have that much
dynamism and change in those stories and
and in different ways I think that often
people who study genes are probably
criticized for the same way well if you
do all this stuff on genes and you see
that people have an authoritarian
personality then that's socially
determinative and everything else is
going to f follow and one of the
exciting things but I don't think any of
us have an answer to Is that the stories
we're telling is that humans do have
agency in that if you went out to vote
and if that actually changes public
policies not only might it change how
people feel about citizenship but it
might feel it might change how the kids
are growing up and then it might change
the institutions that are allowing
people to feel socially isolated or not
when they're in Care Homes and so on a
certain level one of the great things
one of the things that I really
appreciate about being ble to speak to
all of you tonight is that when I write
academic articles they're only read by a
bunch of other academics and that's nice
and I'm glad that I'm contributing to
that discourse in you know sociological
theories of immigration and Corporation
but a lot of what I want to do is I also
want to engage with people who are
living a normal life and talk to them
about my research but then also learn
from them so I try to talk about my
research also to Immigrant communities
and then have people come up to me
afterwards and either tell me that I'm
dead wrong and I don't have it right and
so they can help me think through this
or when people you know it's obviously a
little bit more exciting when people
well not more exciting it's it's just
gratifying when people come up hey that
really matches what I never thought
about it that way but that makes sense
to me um and so at least for me one of
the reasons that I love sociology and
political science both and social
science more generally is that it's
about not only learning for the sake of
learning which is what you fundamentally
have to do to understand what's going on
but then communicating that learning and
then hoping that other people can take
it on and use it for various
purposes no like the 7 got questions
let's just R our Fiona I think someone
needs to get a microphone to Fiona no I
don't need one good for
you save the
electricity um I'd like get John I'm a
recovering politician and uh so I'm
hearing what the three of you have been
saying inms ter of public
policy uh because I'm I'm particular
interest in little children and the
future and in public health as opposed
to all the sickness institutions that we
have and how much better we could use
our public uh
medicat um as a preventor rather than as
a pretty good cure and um I'm wondering
as a result of the research that you
have done um when you're going to take
this show on the road to the politicians
who are going to be elected tonight uh
and get them to do things right
for Fiona I'm not touching that one but
he
F I too am a recovering politician
anybody here want to take that on yeah
so um well I think I right I mean we one
of the things I think that CA does is
nurture our willing us to engage in
those kinds of process and gives us some
confidence I I would say that prior to
being a member of C I'd never had really
that many of those conversations but
actually I think sear is an absolute
model of an Outreach organization that
really you know galvanizes as it were
talent in of a particular form and puts
them in the right places to speak to
people so actually through C when I come
to Canada several occasions myself and
my colleagues have been have have
engaged in in policy debate with with uh
public servants and and with opinion
opinion makers of particular forms with
a specific view of if you like getting
the message out there getting the
conversation going and and hopefully
having informed evidence-based public
policy so again you know you you know in
so far as Canada has something like ca
you have a vehicle for those kinds of
activities I think if you talk to anyone
in CA they're going to say yeah
absolutely you provide us with the
person and we will put the people in
front of them sort of thing so uh you
know you know I again and I have to say
I think like Irene you know to the
extent that those opportunities are
afforded us through this great
organization that's that's that is you
know that's the way forward um and
increasingly what you see is silos I
think particularly in I think countries
like my own between sort of Academia and
and government and I think that's a very
very dangerous State of Affairs for all
sorts of reasons iene I know that you've
spent some time talking to the people in
in the immigration department and
Metropolis conference you want to talk
about that a little bit sure um as as
recovering politicians for those in the
room who are so inclined you know that
politics is not easy um and just like
that academics can debate these things
so you know I could name you a bunch of
people who could come up on this stage
and say that I was entirely wrong that I
have it entirely wrong that
multiculturalism is a really bad thing
especially in Europe and that it
alienates um immigrants it provides bad
labor out outcomes and they would spin a
story to that effect and I can even give
you citations of articles that have been
published on that level um and of course
I disagree and so one level is just as
we have political debates academics have
debates now what I would hope of course
in Academia is that if we can bring
solid research to Bear the weight of the
evidence will go more one way than the
other and I would like to believe that
the weight of the evidence is going to
be going on my side um but you know
maybe just because I talk to my friends
um more maybe less factiously but um I
have had conversations with people in
Ottawa sear facilitated an event where I
did a talk on I have some other research
um that is looking let me let me take a
step back um the group that I am a
member of the social interactions
identity and well-being group on the
advisory committee there's a very
prominent political scientist named
Robert putam and he's done some really
interesting research looking at the
United States that shows that people who
live in more diverse settings and for
his research it was mostly done by ethor
racial categories that are used in the
United States African American Latino
Asian-American white people who live in
those more diverse settings have less
social trust in others and seem less
likely to engage in community-based
activity and it's not just with people
from those other groups but even within
their own group so if you live in a more
diverse setting you're less likely to
engage with others even within your own
group and he has all kinds of controls
to make sure that's it's not just in big
cities people just talk to each other or
or things of this nature um and it's a
pretty you know disquieting conclusion
if we know that immigration is going to
continue in the future especially given
the demography and the Aging population
in many Western countries um and so I
got very interested in how public
policies might influence and mediate a
potential relationship between a
reaction potentially to diversity and
change and then some of these outcomes
in terms of lower trust organizational
involvement Etc uh um a co-author and I
just published a paper last summer in
the Canadian Journal of political
science and this is a paper that I um
shopped actually in our program a few
times um which shows that that
relationship between diversity on the
one hand and less social trust less
organizational involvement on the other
hand if you look across 19 oecd
countries it is mediated by the level of
inequality in the society so more
unequal societies societies where the
rich are really rich and the poor are
really poor that relationship ship
between diversity lower Social Capital
social trust is much more prevalent so
you have more to lose you you have a
sense that have more to lose and so
change in terms of demographic change is
probably felt as more threatening and so
more equal societies have less of this
issue in terms of diversity and social
trust and countries and this is where I
think I'm right um countries around
multiculturalism countries that have
multiculturalism either mitigate the
negative relationship or in the case of
organizational involvement actually you
find that countries that have
multiculturalism and Rising immigration
actually show more organizational
involvement among the majority
population um and that was some of the
research that I presented in Ottawa now
you know social scientists we do these
big findings and you know some of the
people in the room in Ottawa were like
what should I do in Hamilton I don't
know what you should do in Hamilton I
mean you know I don't know Hamilton I
mean I can give you these big ideas but
then at a certain level it's up to other
people to take those big ideas and then
actually tailor it to the local
environment um but you know you hope
your ideas matter and I I have been told
that in the United States my research
was used with other people's work as
well to start um funding some of the
Immigrant settlement work that I talked
about very small like $8 million I think
last year which for the United States of
course is like small change but still
bigger than
zero thank you um did someone get a mic
to rill
midbar there she is I think my you think
your voice car denel has a has a
microphone for you if you'd like to use
it speaks to your social network at C
far that you can actually call out each
one of us by our names good on you khiva
my question is very particularly to
Irene and I'm curious about um uh a
Rising theme in Canada and goes back to
your answer if you are your citizenship
then who are you if you have more than
one citizenship and is that in fact a
problem or is it a hierarchy of
belonging that can be equated back to
public policy responses to your needs so
is multiple citizenship a
problem good question
um the way that I come at my research as
a sociologist I should stay away from
normative political Theory I should stay
away from political partic you know
political messaging and I should really
stick with my data and I can do that but
in the end point I'm coming at a
perspective that I think engagement with
a society Democratic engagement is a
good good thing you know I think that's
a good thing and luckily Alex can give
me some you know data now to show that
if you Empower people in a senior home
that is a good thing so I think you know
being engaged with your Society is a
good thing if that if that if you accept
that
presumption research shows and this
includes some of my research but other
research as well that people who might
have multiple citizenships and act on
those citizenship so actually
participate politically in their
Homeland and in the country that they're
living in that participation in the
Homeland land actually spills over to
increased participation in the domestic
context and so rather than be a zero sum
trade-off like hey if you're doing
things back in your Homeland you're not
doing it here or you know if you're
paying all this attention to what's
going on there you're disengaged here is
actually wrong that it's actually a
positive sum um experience when it comes
to political participation and you can
think of lots of different reasons why
that might be the case and I'll give you
a very specific example of someone I
interviewed this was a young young woman
who was born in Vietnam grew up mostly
in Toronto and she became politically
active with human rights issues in
Vietnam so she was part of pen Canada
she was part of amnesty she was really
oriented to Homeland politics in Vietnam
and a lot of Vietnamese in North America
Canada and the United States are very
concerned with what goes on because
they're a refugee population and
obviously interested in that so you look
at that you go well she's not engaged in
Canadian Society you know isn't that
sort of an issue why are all her
attentions there and then she went up to
Ottawa and started lobbying on behalf of
Human Rights and as she did that she
made connections with other advocacy
organizations on the hill and her
advocacy slowly started to expand to not
only include human rights issues in
Vietnam but also issues for her
community and generally human rights
issues in Canada and so she was able to
leverage the skills that she had in
dealing with human rights in Vietnam
learning how to write a letter learning
how to talk to politicians learning how
to like get people together in a room to
try to work towards some end and she
used it for domestic political ends
let's say so if what you're interested
in and what I'm what I am interested in
is democratic engagement I do not think
that multiple citizenships are a problem
but if you have some other interest in
mind then it might become another well I
don't know if it'll become another
answer but the the the thinking through
it might be different good um I think we
have come to the end of what we can ask
here but there are things to drink and
things to eat so as soon as we finished
you can go out there we can all eat and
drink and talk to everybody and you can
ask anybody any question you'd like to
ask so I think I'm going to welcome
Frank back onto the
stage thank you one and all for uh
joining us this evening um sorry to say
that we draw this part to a close but as
uh Aviva said there's food and drink and
a number of researchers in the room and
others that uh perhap perhaps the
conversation can continue as we say at
SEF far we hope this is not the end of a
conversation but the beginning of
one I want to thank the uh three
participants for uh making such an
interesting evening and uh as I promised
at the beginning it would be
thought-provoking and I'm sure it has
been for all of us thank you each and
every one of you for making this a great
event and thank you for your supportive
uh sear and thank you for being part of
this wonderful
organization
thank
you so with that I uh invite you next
door to uh uh some food and drink and uh
and further conversation thanks once
again thanks aiva for making this work
thank you very
much